oh hello and welcome to the pandemi's
it will go down as one of the most
surreal shows in history
where the audience was virtual and stars
dialed in from home
british comedian john oliver took best
talk show from his sofa
first christ producers boasting they
broadcast from 114 locations around the
world
this is so freaking weird
watzman with its socially resonant
themes starring regina king
bagged the most awards with eleven while
canadians show
shit's creek achieved an emmy's first
cleaning up in the comedy categories for
its sixth and final series stars were
topical
referencing covid as well as social
unrest and politics
this isn't what it should have been
jimmy but but you know what
i'm still rooting for everybody black
because black stories
black performances and black lives
matter
and the winner of the night's biggest
award best drama went to succession
winning seven in total it's british
writer and creator jesse armstrong
beaming in from london and thank you to
the virus
uh for keeping us all apart this year
and thank you to uh president trump for
his crummy and uncoordinated response
uh and thank you to um boris johnson and
his government for doing the same in my
country
uh and thank you to all the nationalist
and sort of quasi-nationalist
governments in the world who are exactly
the opposite of what we need right now
and um thank you to the media moguls who
do so much to keep them in power
so um thank you concluding this virtual
ceremony
which for now at least will be the new
normal for awards
lucy cotter sky news